uh good morning afternoon or evening
everybody wherever you are I'm Brian
Howard from Sheffield in UK
I'm going to talk for about 45 minutes
and then while I do it to draw breath
and encourage you to ask questions or
make comments at that stage
until then I would be grateful if you
didn't interrupt me unless there's
something that I've said that's not
clear to you
if that's the case then um please
request clarification but I I do need to
admit that this is a new format for me
and I apologize now if I miss your
request for clarification
right the topic today then is certifying
competence and where I want to begin
with this is really to take it into
three phases
we're going to focus initially on what I
mean by competence
and then we're going to look at ways in
which that can be measured and the
strengths and weaknesses of those
methods
and then I'm going to explore the
consequences of that for the
certification of confidence if that's
okay with you
right so the first stage that I want to
move on to then is what do we mean by
competence and uh I'm going to uh deal
with this from uh
a number of different perspectives as I
said first of all the European directive
uh 2200 2010 83 EU introduces a number
of important Concepts and amongst those
is a clear emphasis on competence
the difficulty with this is that
specifically it requires appropriate
prior Education and Training to those
who care for or kill or use animals for
a scientific purpose
and in addition those who design
procedures in which animals will be used
and these require all of these
categories apart from the last one of
those requires appropriate supervision
until competence has been established
oh
this therefore is going to focus very
much on those sort of characteristics
arising out of the European directive
but I will make it much more General
because there are issues that we're
dealing with here we've got a much more
Global implication than those that I've
simply summarized there
the definition of competence that we've
got here used by the um EU skill in
lifelong learning glossary is that there
are four parts to it cognitive
functional personal and ethical
I guess one could chop it up in many
different ways but that is a convenient
way of making sure that we don't miss
out too much of what we're dealing with
commonly we think of functional
competences being the ability to do a
job but you'll see from this that there
are additional aspects that we also need
to take into account
the emphasis on competence arises from a
number of different considerations
which include satisfying concerns in the
public about animal well-being and
that's an issue which is arising in many
parts of the world now as animal rights
activity increases in intensity
there are also issues in relation to
Scientific rigor because obviously if an
experiment is performed by competent
people it can be considered to be much
more likely to have scientific rigor and
therefore to produce a more appropriate
scientific result which will not bring
disrepute into the biological sciences
and finally it facilitates the movement
of personnel from one Arena to another
and that's a topic that I'll come back
to later on
although the directive doesn't actually
Define what it means by competence
there's no shortage of definitions
elsewhere
for the purposes of this presentation
I'm intending to draw a distinction
between the words competence and
competency with a y at the end
the latter competence C relates to the
deployment of a set of related knowledge
skills and abilities to successfully
perform a function
the focus is on
the defined work setting
in contrast I'll use the word competence
or implore or competencies
in a much broader context that
encompasses demonstrable outputs of both
performance and behavior
and this may relate to a system or set
of minimum standards required for
Effective performance
so competence encompasses not only
technical skill and deep understanding
of the rationale for actions that are
being taken
the much wider awareness of and
sensitivity to societal interest in
what's being done
this includes an ability to respond to
the unexpected in a scientifically and
ethically appropriate way in other words
to handle emergencies effectively
to work professionally and effectively
with colleagues so that the output is in
fact a joined up output rather than
single inputs
and to maintain High personal and
workplace standards
so we can see competence then as lying
in the center of a group of activities
relating around core knowledge and
knowledge at a greater depth meaning
understanding and awareness of what's
happening and an ability to use that
information in developing strategies
but it also includes professionalism
ethical considerations
manual and technical skills and
resourcefulness in other words drawing
on inner understandings of issues that
might be arising in order to take things
forward
and so how these competencies going to
be developed then and we can see that
there are a number of levels of
competence that are shown in the table
here
starting off simply with knowledge
knowledge is what you learn by reading
through a text
subsequent to that there is
understanding is appreciating what that
knowledge means
the next stage is application of that
knowledge the ability
to
use the information in order to solve a
particular problem
there is then a wider requirement for
synthesis whereby the knowledge is used
not only in that holistic sense but also
as a means of developing
new ideas and New Concepts and taking
those forward and finally the deepest
levels if you like of learning are those
which relate to the evaluation of
strategies so not only can you develop
strategies but also you can think back
how is this strategy going to be
beneficial or is it going to work or
does it have shortcomings and to select
from a number of strategies any
particular route forward
now many other qualities associated with
competence are going to be acquired in
the workplace rather than during the
course of formal training
although the quality of formal training
is absolutely Paramount in establishing
a trajectory for individual personal
development
I'm proposing to address in this talk
not only the characteristics of that
basic training but the importance of
continuing professional development
which means learning that takes place
after the initial phases if you like are
becoming competent and including the
need for guidance and structure as one
moves down that list of depths of
learning
Education and Training is one way of
developing some of the basic elements of
competence but it's not an end in itself
firstly there are other elements of
competence such as personal attributes
professionalism the ability to work with
others are most unlikely to be developed
in a formal didactic environment
there's also a need to select
individuals before they engage with
educational training to ensure that they
are the sorts of people who are likely
to be able to make best use of what's
being presented to them and if there are
shortcomings identified then they can be
addressed in uh an appropriate way or
people if it's felt that they're not
likely to become competent in the sense
that's required they could have some
alternative strategies presented to them
for developing their careers
in addition during the course of
election if it seemed that there are
shortcomings in particular personal
attitudes then these can be addressed in
other manners perhaps by coaching or by
some supervision mechanism
often education and prior experience are
requirements for entrance to particular
levels of activity within the laboratory
animal science field
for example the aylat training in the
United States
or the UK home office require a certain
level of background education and
knowledge before they enter a formal
training course
one reason for this is that individuals
have sufficient background knowledge to
enable them to assimilate information
that is presented to them during formal
training
and another reason is that it gives you
an indication that those individuals are
able to absorb information and to make
use of it because they've obviously
demonstrated this already
now learning can take place in many
different ways
and
one of those
or one of the routes for developing
learning is shown in this diagram here
which is developing competence beyond
that initial training stage and it's
done by reflective learning
this is the cold learning cycle where
the learner carries out an action either
under supervision or independently
because this can take place at any point
in an individual's career
and then having done that action they
reflect on how it went shortcomings and
strengths and interpret why it went like
that so there's a great deal of thought
here into what may seem to be a fairly
simple deviation from normality but of
course in a scientific context uh
scientists who are publishing papers and
developing original research will
already be carrying out this sort of
process the next phase then is to say
right having interpreted what this means
I'm going to do things in a slightly
different way to see if I can get a
better outcome and so you alter the way
that you're approaching things and then
move forward to a new cycle of activity
in which uh hopefully your competence
and abilities will generally improve
another aspect of developing competency
is the Collegiate environment in which
somebody is working
if somebody has got a functional role
within a deeply caring and supportive
community and much more likely to
develop competence than they are if
they're working individually or in a
hostile environment where there are
considerable
fractions between individual researchers
or individual Care Care staff
uh we tend to call in UK we call this
culture a culture of care it's a culture
of mutual support in which the animal is
in many ways Central to the process
um but individuals are working together
in an attempt to ensure that the animal
gets the best deal that's possible
where
an organization or those responsible for
overseeing the activities of people
within such an organization need to be
fully plugged into that cultural care
they need to not only have bought into
it but they need to understand it and
where sources of support come from
initial learning and training in
laboratory animal science is usually
delivered through a standard curriculum
this is linked to Define series of
learning outcomes
the benefit of this is that it enables
the student to identify what needs to
come out of learning and helps them and
the students to focus on the key issues
and it provides a yardstick for
measuring learning and achievement
this considerable uniformity in the
learning outcomes that will identified
by regulatory bodies and others in
different countries so that's
encouraging at least we have a core of
expectation of or a competent individual
will have
both teachers and Learners must have the
same expectations on what they are
supposed to address and how they're
supposed to address them and this can
obviously vary at different times during
the process of development of knowledge
education training and competence
and we need to bear in mind always that
formal educational courses only deliver
competency to carry out specific tasks
so there's a need for a variety of
inputs in order to develop the rounded
competent individual
we also need to recognize that
shortfalls in learning which will
inevitably occur need to be identified
and corrected during practice
additional considerations include
ensuring that the learner is prepared
for the rigors of real working in other
words an important part of this initial
training is to make sure that the
learner has got the skills necessary to
continue the learning afterwards
I've talked about critical reflection
and the importance of that and I'll just
uh Carry On by
emphasizing the fact that it's important
that the learner can step back from
events examine their own performance and
draw conclusions from that which will be
of a personal benefit
effective training programs need to
include an element of preparation for
learning as I've indicated just now
and some of that will work within the
laboratory animal landscape in any case
for example team working developing the
three r's
approaches towards ethics management of
critical incidents that will undoubtedly
occur during the working life and the
development of key personal skills
probably it's extremely useful to
develop some of these skills alongside
the workplace in other words you can
have courses which are either
intercalated amongst
practical work experience or you can get
Block release from a practical role in
order to attend classes and then go back
to carry out the practical classes
within the lab
this sort of activity is used for
example by the alac scheme for training
animal caretakers and also by The
Institute of animal technology
in fact in some ways the philosopher
guidelines the Federation of European
laboratory animal science associations
for bench workers bench scientific
workers recommend that the most
appropriate way of training May well be
an apprenticeship scheme which takes the
issue obviously considerably further
forward
key to following up this formal training
is a period of developed competence
because I don't believe that an
individual coming out of this form of
training as I said before should be
regarded as competent they can be
regarded as having competency but in
themselves they need additional skills
in order to be able to fulfill their
role completely and this usually
involves a period of supervision and
that period of supervision has a number
of aims firstly to embed skills that
have been learned in a classroom
environment into formal activity
to provide for professional growth and
development of the Learner in other
words to take that learning forwards as
well as to embed it in practice
it's important to protect the welfare of
animals so that they're not harmed by
individuals during this process
and to keep a watchful eye on the
performance of the Learner in order to
ensure that they're acting
professionally and ethically
so learning in this context is an
experimental process and it provides a
meaningful appreciation of issues that
individuals are likely to meet later in
life
typically those caring for and working
with animals will be supervised by a
more experienced colleague who is
competent in the relative areas of work
often several colleagues competent in
different areas so that they have skills
which can be imparted from several
angles
both learner and supervisor need to feel
comfortable with the arrangement they
need to be clear objectives and ideally
there should be a senior person who's
out with this relationship who can
monitor progress and draw up a schedule
for tracking how the individual is
developing
it helps the learner to become familiar
with practical day-to-day workplace and
it develops formative working
relationships with seniors with whom
they may be collaborating subsequently
it also develops procedural time
management skills prioritization skills
within an appropriate laboratory animal
setting and that's an important part of
future career development
I want to move on now to examine some of
the difficulties which will arise in
terms of measuring competence
one thing that I have mentioned very
briefly and I will come back to it again
is that competence is not at all or none
phenomenon it doesn't mean I am
competent or I'm not competent I can be
different or a different levels of
competence that we can identify in
different areas
but at the outset we need to before we
start measuring we need to identify what
level of competence and in what areas we
are seeking to make our measurements in
order to satisfy legal scientific and
ethical requirements we'll discuss that
again later
partly the decision as to where we're
going to focus our emphasis will be
determined by what is the effect of a
shortfall in performance because
developing competence in people costs
money and time and resources and we
don't want to do that if in fact it's
not going to be of any benefit to us
we've looked at some of the benefits
earlier but at this stage you would be
saying what would be the impact on my
establishment if this individual isn't
is not competent
well practically it's likely that you
would carry out a cost benefit
assessment and you will say look it's
going to cost this much in terms of time
resources people space and there is this
much benefit coming from it and you will
perhaps modulate the amount of effort
that you spend in developing that
competence
when we come to the assessment process
we're going to have to look at a number
of characteristics of that in order to
ensure that we are able to
find the appropriate requirement
so for example here in looking at
practicality we can say that um
is there sufficient resources in order
to develop the program of competence
that we have in mind uh it may be that
you can argue for more resources it may
be that they're not available and
therefore you need to look at a
different way of developing competence
but in terms of assessment that's going
to be quite an important figure
we need to make sure that the assessment
process itself is valid in other words
how well does it measure the uh
the aspects of competence that you want
to assess
it needs to be robust it means that if
you've got a number of different
assessors would they all come up with
the same answer how well will the
results of the assessment reflect what
the candidate is actually capable of
doing
and finally it needs to be consistent so
that measuring a number of individuals
all of whom are going to vary in in
slight respects from one way or another
that you come up with a consistent
output which everybody can have great
faith in
oh
uh nice light's a moving room I think
right so if we're going to be examining
candidates in order to assess uh their
stage of development
we first need to make sure that we cover
the key issues at an appropriate depth
and range
questions that we ask need to be
completely unambiguous so that there is
no issue of the learner not being sure
what's required of them
we need to allow candidates plenty of
opportunity to demonstrate whether they
are outstanding mediocre or poor
they need to be fair so that different
candidates would achieve similar or with
similar levels of learning would obtain
a similar result
in other words there must be no apparent
bias because somebody who has focused on
particular aspects of training but
ignored others would do better than
another who had perhaps focused on
different areas
and of course it needs to be practicable
it needs to be something that can be
easily done and effectively done as
we've seen already
now the approach is currently available
for the direct assessment of competence
are inevitably unsatisfactory
particularly using the wider definition
that I presented to you earlier
obviously it would be ethically
unacceptable to deliberately create an
unanticipated complication in the
handling or scientific usable laboratory
animal and because competence is a
measure if you like of the ability of an
individual to deal with such a situation
in real life that's an aspect or
performance that we're not going to be
able to measure easily
but in fact all of the assessment
strategies have got weaknesses and
strengths and very quickly I just want
to run through some of those
first of all we've seen that competence
is a stage Beyond competency it doesn't
just mean knowledge and it doesn't just
mean a manual skill
but it means or it incorporates those
two functions and we need to recognize
that they can be assessed relatively
easily
for example often standards of
Competency are set by accrediting bodies
or other regulatory authorities and the
appropriate Education and Training may
be delivered by a number of providers
who sometimes themselves participate in
the assessment
each uh or for an example of that would
be in the UK where there are three
different accrediting bodies authorized
by the home office to provide training
and assess people who have been trained
now here we're dealing with competency
and not competence
so each um devolves Education and
Training to individual training
providers will also conduct assessments
and although they are doing this uh
independently this is some oversight of
the standards within a particular
accrediting group
the accreditation scheme offered by
philosa similarly focuses on the quality
of provision of Education rather than
the outcomes of education and in fact
that is a fault I think of most
accreditation processes that we have at
the present time is that they are
looking much more at the quality of
input rather than the quality of output
not sure that's not true of all of
course in the Alat scheme is if you like
a measure of output that the philosophy
scheme itself Falls slightly short on on
that measure
models such as those I've just outlined
provide flexibility in the preparation
of personnel for examination but
inevitably there are varying levels of
prescription of the way in which
competency is assessed
I just want to provide a word of warning
at this stage and that is the tendency
of those who are delivering and
assessing training uh to look at the
issues as a number of modules and fear
this is an issue that's going to arise
with the new European directive because
the requirement there is for people to
have completed a number of modules and
the danger with modules is that training
at all these different levels tends to
compartmentalize learning and many of
the strategies for assessment reinforce
that compartmentalization so that
learning is piecemeal and the quality of
learning is therefore potentially
compromised
and while a particular training program
or national accreditation body can
consciously or unconsciously buy into
this process it needs to be realized
that there is if if you like a
compartmentalization taking place and
somehow this needs to be unbundled and
then one way of doing that is of course
during supervision at the end of the
training period
in general
excuse me after the
um written or after the formal training
of this sort students are assessed by
written examination
these vary widely in format and perhaps
the Communist is the multiple choice
question which can vary from a simple
yes no or true false selection to a
selection of a truest statement from
amongst a number of others
but of course there are quite a number
of different strategies
and some of those are listed on this uh
this slide here
so we have multiple choice or true false
questions and that's the sort that I've
just described or extended matching
questions in which a number of scenarios
are presented and the person being
assessed is required to pick the most
likely scenario from the number of
others in response to a particular
prompt
there may be short answer questions
longer essay questions which may be open
book or closed book people may be
required to complete projects there may
be oral presentations which are quite
common for example at a PhD level
and then preparation of portfolios so a
whole range of potential strategies for
assessing knowledge and these vary in
their ability to assess the higher
levels of knowledge that we looked at
earlier
one problem with multiple choice
questions is that they're very difficult
to set and it can be very difficult to
make them good measures of deep learning
on the other hand if we move down this
list coming down in this direction here
we find that the preparation of
portfolios is a very good way of
measuring the ability of somebody to put
information together and to structure it
in a way that demonstrates uh deeper
levels of understanding and perhaps also
synthesis and selection but on the other
hand as we move down this list it
becomes
increasingly difficult to actually Mark
objectively the outcome of that
assessment a multiple choice question
you will finish up with a number and
that will tell you how many uh correct
selections were made
in the case of a portfolio there's a lot
of opinion goes into that as to
precisely whether or not it meets
standards and of course these standards
can be defined but nonetheless two
people marking the same portfolio will
quite possibly come up with rather
different
marks for that portfolio and this can
lead to a lack of consistency
oh
another
aspect of the process of course is the
ability to Mark and to
provide feedback on different assessment
methods
and
I think here we're going to have to
realize that whatever we're going to be
doing it's not going to be a watertight
solution to understanding how much a
student knows and understands
moving down the list uh that I was
discussing just now so let's come back
to this one uh as I've said easier to um
easy to set the questions it's easy to
ask somebody just to produce a portfolio
about your performance as
a bench scientists successes you had uh
things that have gone wrong and how
you've dealt with those but much more
difficult to make a multiple choice exam
much more difficult however to be
precise as to the scoring that you would
give here and therefore we can see that
there's if you like a cost benefit
assessment in the way that we would move
downwards
it's much more difficult to objectively
assess deeper levels of understanding
and uh we need to realize that we need
different strategies for doing this
although the portfolio May provide a way
in uh there are shortcomings in the
portfolio it may happen that the learner
uh finds it more difficult to appreciate
the information and the learning that's
taken place
um and therefore somebody who's slick at
putting together information will appear
to have an advantage over somebody who
is
if you like less acquainted with the
portfolio of your system of examination
another difficulty that we have of
course is in the assessment of practical
skills and we'll look at those a little
bit later on but there are techniques of
it or for reasonably objectively
managing uh or assetting bench skills
um but again there are shortcomings as
well with many of those
just a number of Quick points about the
examination process such as we've laid
it out in in these slides and first is
to make sure that the process is robust
so that it produces the same result if
marked by different examiners and if
different students with the same
knowledge took the same assessment form
they would produce the same results
uh people being assassinated to know
precisely what skills and criteria on
judgment are being used
we are examiner ideally should not be
the trainer you want a fresh pair of
eyes looking at the assessment process
and often
um there is benefit particularly in the
case of practical Assessments in
ensuring that the
examiner not only looks at how a student
is demonstrating practical skills but
also is able to score these in an
objective way using a check sheet or a
mark box and in addition may ask a few
oral questions to better understand
whether the student has a good grasp of
what he or she is doing
where you've got a number of assessors
as you are likely to have if you're
dealing with a practical examination or
a large number of students dealing with
a written examination then it's quite
important that there should be some sort
of quality control between the assessors
to make sure that the assessment
standards are uniform
learning acquired
in other ways can be much more difficult
to follow I'm thinking here for example
of e-learning Assessments where a
student has carried out quite a lot of
learning online and the formal types of
examinations we've looked at can be
applied but are generally more difficult
and less robust
and what we might do there is to look
for e-assessment techniques and there
are a number of those
um which we can deploy
particularly
beneficial in a sense if they're dealing
with longer essay type questions or
portfolio collections is the
availability of antiplagiarism software
which can be used to check that this is
a student's original work and also
e-technology can be used to support a
learner during the process of learning
for example by providing online feedback
through a Dropbox where a student
submits a piece of work it's marked and
goes back into the Dropbox and the
student can re-access it and get
immediate feedback about the performance
learning acquired alongside an
experienced animal caretaker or bench
scientist involves the integration of
manual skills as we've seen with
knowledge and understanding and that can
be assessed at the time when the student
is at the bench or in the Animal
Facility but it can be difficult to
quantify as we've already seen
often it's the supervisor who assesses
the competence of their supervisees and
so there needs to be clear guidance as
to precisely what those criteria will be
because obviously there will be
different supervisors
working with different supervisees but
there needs to be that level of
consistency that I've referred to before
uh there are difficulties because of
interpersonal relationships that may
arise between supervised and supervisees
a supervisor may have a student they've
got very little confidence in and even
if the student performs well they may be
disinclined to award a good Mark
it's often better to have an independent
person or an independent body to review
attainment against predefined measures
in other words external to this close
supervision process there is another
layer if you like of examination to make
sure that the examiners are working to a
common format
such an arrangement is facilitated under
the new European directive because
there's a requirement there for
establishments to identify somebody to
ensure that staff are adequately
educated competent and continuously
trained
Central assessment of this sort also
simplifies identification of persons who
are deemed competent to supervise in
other words more advanced individuals
and they can be taken forward to deal
with more complex activities
but assessment at this stage has to be
much more holistic than simply a looking
at examination results
we must also incorporate into this a
mechanism for our recognizing
competencies which have been developed
outside a formal program
for example veterinarians and surgeons
may be skilled in tasks such as the
administration compounds or the conduct
of surgery but they may not fully
appreciate the differences between
laboratory animals and larger farm
animals for example or pet animals or on
the other hand of human subjects we need
to recognize the prior learning may be
incomplete or biased and so we may need
to provide an explanation about things
in a different context and one of the
challenges is to recognize that Learners
almost by definition come from a wide
range of different backgrounds and when
we come to measure competence we need to
be allowing for the learning that's
taking place in other places
okay so then how are we going to
actually make sure that we have a scheme
which will successfully certificate the
competence of individuals first I've
indicated that we need to recognize
there are different areas of competence
and in this um somewhat
um dramatic picture if you like we've
got a number of individuals each of whom
has got specific competences I'd like to
think that each of those can do their
own job better than anybody else in that
group
uh surely the surgeon should be a better
surgeon your anesthetist should be a
better anesthetist or the
anesthesiologist if we're going to use
American terminology
the circulating nurse or would be the
theater nurse would
um be using a different set of skills
from those which probably the surgeon
would easily deploy and so each of the
persons in that picture is competent but
each of them is competent at a slightly
different theme but all of them are
working in a surgical theater
and I think that's something we need to
bear in mind when we're looking at what
we mean by areas of competence it's not
often recognized
the other thing that we need to make
sure is that people can develop
competence to deeper levels we've been
talking mainly about the uh the learner
who is at a relatively early stage in
development but that person will
hopefully
having just achieved a basic competence
be able to move forward to become an
assistant surgeon and subsequently to
become the chief surgeon uh responsible
for the management of the surgical
program
and so what we've got here is not only
competence in different areas but
competence at different levels and that
as I've said is something which very
frequently is overlooked and we don't
give ourselves sufficient latitude to be
able to deal with that
in a sense the European directive for
its shortcomings in terms of uh
speaking a great deal about competence
but not actually telling us what they
mean by that does recognize in this
diagram that somebody who has completed
their formal training program is not yet
competent they come through here
they come to a stage when they require
it acquire additional information
whether they're Care staff or whether
they are bench scientists but then they
develop their competence and continue to
develop competence on a lifelong scale
so even within the directive which
appears to have shortcomings there is in
fact a clear Way Forward in terms of
identifying competences
any accreditation scheme for flexibility
or or a certification scheme
requires to accommodate these varying
levels of competence
individual establishments will
undoubtedly prefer a particular
deployment of personalities level
depends partly on finance it depends
partly on the the management structure
within the establishment and the type of
research activities that may be taking
place
so it's a certification scheme needs to
be sufficiently well drafted to make it
clear precisely what the requirements
are and what has been certified
and that needs to be reflected in any
documentation that's issued
I've also indicated that the scheme
would need to accommodate expertise
developed and accredited elsewhere and
this includes by not only e-learning but
International or multinational
organizations associations and companies
for example an experienced researcher in
the United States should have their
expertise recognized if they wish to
relocate and work in the European Union
or vice versa
however the expertise which they bring
with them when they travel is frequently
not recognized and such people are
required to undertake a training program
that is crazy because they already have
many of the skills that the training
program is trying to impart at a much
higher and deeper level but in addition
to that there's a great deal of material
they certainly don't need they do need
to become acquainted with local legal
and Regulatory processes but most of the
training that they will receive in this
way is irrelevant
now at the European level some
flexibility may be coming along because
of the proposal to formally recognize a
number of different accrediting bodies
and to monitor their activity with a
broad European platform which will have
oversight of what's taking place there
the accreditation scheme operated by
philaso that's been in place now for
more than 10 years demonstrates that
even higher educational establishments
are becoming more receptive these days
to external and indeed transnational
validation and accreditation of their
activities
often people from unconventional
backgrounds
as I've already indicated are required
to undertake formal education and
training and that is completely
unnecessary
although we've seen that learning
outcomes are widely used in modern
curriculum development
they've unfortunately not yet been
properly incorporated into instruments
of assessment
uh however if we see them as building
blocks of competence we see them as
blocks if you like of development then
it is possible to use learning outcomes
as a measure of Prior learning learning
in different places for example an
agricultural worker who's having to work
in a research facility working perhaps
with agricultural animals could have
their existing skills recognized and
that can be done if we build our
assessment process around learning
outcomes rather than teaching inputs
we need flexibility without sacrificing
standards
however as long as validation and
certification remains at a national
level individual Learners are assessed
against highly variable standards
speaking at an international level so
what is needed is if you like more
uniformity and are coming together of
standards in different uh parts of the
world
as I said before there's currently too
much emphasis on basic knowledge and
skills and too little on attitudes
and for me the underlying personal
skills such as ethical awareness
curiosity critical and analytical skills
flexibility professionalism are much
more important in context of um
competence then are the basic things
which are frequently tested
too often accreditation and
certification is based on a checklist
methodology
but we need to find ways of developing
those competencies in an environment to
which I've referred earlier as a culture
of care
deeper levels of learning are obviously
much more difficult to assess but
nonetheless there are ways of
approaching them one of those ways
is to use the bird's eye view
in which there are multiple mini audits
of learner similar to a 360 degree
appraisal process and these can focus on
things such as welfare planning
preparation record keeping
interpretation and ideas for change so
that by asking a number of different
individuals who are working with this
person in different contexts for their
views on a number of items of this sort
it's possible to form a holistic view of
how competent that individual is
another approach to assessing higher
level learning is the focused review
which can be written on oral and it can
focus on the activities
of the individual concern by getting
them to reflect on things that they've
done similar to a portfolio but going
beyond that and holistically reviewing
the opportunities that this presents for
moving forward
and the third method that could be used
is that an assessor might actually watch
the learner during a particularly
demanding task in the workplace
a bench scientist carrying out a tricky
piece of work or
um
somebody designing a study sitting with
them while they're putting the study
together and this person then has an
opportunity to ask questions about the
way things are being done they may
provide guidance or even supervision if
that's necessary to secure Animal
Welfare but at the end of the process
they can assign a score which
unfortunately is likely to be
qualitative rather than quantitative but
nonetheless gives a possibility of
developing a marking scheme the
difficulty with all these systems of
course is that there is a need for
moderation because none of them are
completely objective and that is
inevitably going to be a problem at this
level
increasingly pressure is going to arise
on the association between assessment
and learning to take account of the rise
of interest in learning Technologies and
I've touched base with this already
finally a couple of words about the
awarding body
and
I'm sorry we'll skip the slide
I've missed a slide even better right
okay
um let's move forward then to the
accreditation of competence it needs to
provide confidence in the quality of
development and assessment of personnel
it needs to ensure that Animal Welfare
is best supported
should facilitate free movement
Personnel between establishments member
states and indeed more globally
it should improve the quality of science
using live animals
and it should provide reassurance to the
public funders regulators and others
that the individual who has been
certified in this way is in fact on the
standard that is worthwhile having
so in summary then
um
an approval or a certification process
needs to command the confidence of all
players trainers trainees and National
authorities
and therefore it is likely to need to be
an international process it needs to be
sustainable and consistent standards
the assessors need to be recognized as
uh appropriately uh skilled and trained
and competent
there needs to be Independence complete
independence from the provider of
trading or the organization that
provides training and so the
certification board can't draw its funds
from these sources although it's going
to need money in order to make its
activities proportionate and affordable
and with that ladies and gentlemen I'd
like to conclude for now and invite you
to ask questions thank you very much for
your attendance
if you have any questions
oh I like silence it's great
foreign
okay
the the first question I have here is
how would you certify something
internationally rather than
institutionally
the way in which this
the only way in which this can be done
is for there to be an international
agreement between areas where this
competence needs to be recognized
on the standards that are going to be
used
and there would need to be an
overarching body which would be
responsible for the accreditation and
certification process in both areas
in other words if within the European
context it's ABS easy to move forward
because there's been the development of
a European platform which effectively
represents all of the member states of
the European Union and that body will
set standards which accrediting bodies
will need to apply in other words
they're going to oversee a number of
different accredited bodies to ensure
that there is a common standard and that
provides a mechanism for certifying the
competence of individuals
internationally
please come back if I haven't answered
that question to your satisfaction
well copies of my presentation be
available uh yes I believe they will
um the difference between competence and
competency competency is a basic basic
knowledge and skill to carry out a
specific task for example you want an
animal technician to be competent at
cleaning out a mouse cage
you would expect them to have the
knowledge and to have the technical
skill to handle mice to be able to do
that in a satisfactory glp appropriate
way or whatever it might be
the individual is not necessarily in a
good position to deal with major
emergencies if a mouse escapes you
wouldn't necessarily expect somebody who
is competent at doing that basic task to
be able to assess how best to handle and
those that's disappeared across the
floor at high speed and so that latter
person requires somebody who is
competent who can say right this is what
I need to do and to get down and get
that sorted out so that's the
distinction I'm drawing competency is a
relatively basic set of skills and tasks
whereas competence is a much wider and
more holistic thing
can you define the description of the
new European directive there was one I
think actually or a guy gave a pointer
to the website and I'll just try and put
that slide up again I find it
um
excuse me I'll just close that screen
for a moment and try and find the slide
that's got the web pointer
as well
right so you'll see then that um the the
slide that I've just put up gives the
the website for the European directive
um
I apologize it's a fairly long one I
hope that you can read it but if not if
you if you Google for the directive
2010 63 EU you you will I think find it
there it's the output on one of the X
booking groups
um
how do we get a copy of the slides in
the presentation I gather uh Don
cookshang told me this is going to be on
the website so you will have access to
that and I believe also it will be
available as a podcast
um
if somebody gets training uh for example
the alas learning library
um let me look at this question in full
no sorry I'm not seeing the full
question are you saying that if somebody
gets training from for example the alas
learning library that the alas
qualification or the a-lat are we
talking Alat here I think
um with their qualification I'm sorry I
can't read the whole question here
um
can I skip that if you could come back
and give me some clarification I'll uh
I'll try and answer it
um there's a question here that ends in
and proficiency
oh dear I'm I'm not making these
questions out very clearly how closely
correlated are the developments in new
technologies and techniques with
relative competence in fact they're
probably no worse than the more
traditional methods
I'm not going to say that they're better
but there is an opportunity as
um the new learning methodologies move
forward for assessments to incorporate
if you like virtual reality scenarios in
which case it would be possible probably
to get a better indication of how
somebody will respond in an emergency
than it would be in any other way so I I
do envisage that in time not at the
present I think but but in time it will
be possible for these new technologies
to be even better than the traditional
methods but of course some of the
benefits of e-learning and e-assessing
Technologies are already with us in
terms of the ease of marking and helping
students in the course of their uh their
learning development do you think that
Independence is an accreditation process
or in an accreditation process means
that you have to pay for it
um I'm afraid so everything comes with a
cost
um it may be that the cost is drawn up
by national authorities who say well we
need to set standards or uh National
regulatory bodies or it may have to be
borne by the individual but in general
it tends to be not falling on the
individual shoulders at the present time
so I'm optimistic that the costs which
are inevitably involved will be met from
relatively neutral sources as far as the
individual researcher is concerned but
not obviously is the establishment
how do you go about getting a company's
internal training program certified by
the state government or whatever
um
a tricky one but I think I'm talking
above individual companies at this level
there are opportunities for
organizations to
or or let's start with States first
there are opportunities for states to
get together and set up problem
platforms I think it would be helpful to
falasa if alas were to communicate with
them and to open discussions to see
what common ground there is between the
two bodies now I appreciate that ALS is
more concerned perhaps with the training
of Animal Care staff at the present time
than the training of scientists but I
also understand that um other aspects of
training are rising in priority and it
may well be that there's sharing at that
level also but when the when the
European platform has already been
established it should be possible for an
American input
to that or Canadian Australian wherever
it might be and if you like initially
for a loose understanding of memorandum
of understanding if you like right those
are your standards these are ours can we
come to a common ground and then having
come to a common ground and that ought
to be possible
then I think to move forward and say
right we'll accredit and say this is
accredited according to our particular
standard but our standard is matched
against uh broader standard elsewhere so
I I do see a mechanism for it although I
do appreciate that it is not a
straightforward process
ah the question again if training is
provided by alas's learning library
would you consider their certificate of
completion valid
um the problem with any scheming or this
nature including als's learning library
is that it doesn't give me a great deal
of information about the
skills level of the individual who has
completed the examination
um
there is obviously a statement from the
person's supervisor and so forth but
again no consistency there so I would be
worried about the overall validity of
such a premises and
I think also it is assessing
knowledge
and some levels of understanding the McQ
questions that are being used by the
registration board are reasonably robust
but they don't go down to the deeper
levels that I'm calling competency and
to be quite honest much of what
currently takes place doesn't go to
those levels as well so I do feel that
we've got some distance to go with that
yet but good luck on the journey I think
it's a very important one
okay I think I've skipped through the
questions if I've missed anybody I
apologize we've got um
two minutes left
assessing professionalism oh
um my approach to that is the 360 degree
appraisal approach if you like the
bird's eye view uh difficult to make it
robust very difficult to ensure that
we've got uh all aspects covered but it
seems to me that if you're dealing with
the supervisor or person in the line
manager above people from below people
from horizontally you're much more
likely to get a good view
about the performance of that individual
in terms of assetting and issuing
certificates of competence
um there's some work to be done I think
in making sure that the assessments that
are done in uniform not impossible
there's a lot that can be done you know
because this is written information and
similarly if you're doing uh verbal
presentations they can be tape recorded
or they uh digitally recorded and an
overall assessor can look at that and
say right this balances so I think there
are ways forward yes
um but I I do believe it's an important
subject it's something we're going to
have to work out
foreign
in which case thank you to everybody
it's been a pleasant experience in some
ways
and I wish you all a successful
conference